the may 2013 cover of Time magazine is
entitled the me me me generation
Millennials are lazy entitled narcissist
who still live with their parents why
they will save us all it's written by
Joel Stein they say that Millennials
will save us all because they have time
to ruminate on things and they will come
up with a better way to do things they
don't they're not sort of driven by a
schedule maybe or the responsibility as
prior generations were and so maybe they
will actually have more time to come up
with answers to some of the things that
plague us currently your thoughts well
as you started that question i was
thinking one thing and you finished it i
thought another oh that there's i am i
feel i've been in a dis fortunate
position where i can think about unusual
thoughts and i try to let myself think
about unusual things so to me that is
quite important however I because I do
that I noticed the contrast between me
and some of the people around me you you
you know you need to turn these thoughts
into actions one of the things i found
it always amazes me when it happens that
i should i know it's not but it does
amaze me i have some idea that i think
this is brilliant okay and I go and I
tell somebody about it and they don't do
anything I'm like but I'm expecting to
grab me by the shoulders and say Laxus
that's such a brilliant idea let me do
at least seventy percent of the work for
you and I'm always up for some reason I
always feel disappointed when they won't
do it but the thing is and i have this
delusion again again but the thing is is
people it's a self-centered view the
world people are all trying to get on
with their lives people every day they
get up and they had to have an
inspiration for that day and they do it
and they're kind of set on doing that
and suddenly some idiot comes along and
says all you know what about making a
short film which is controlled by brain
waves isn't that a brilliant idea and
that person's like yeah sounds really
interesting and then they
Carrie ha what they need to do so I
think it's all very well kind of
ruminating coming with good ideas but
there needs to be some goal driven
element I believe as well now this but
it's funny i have i have taught some
music students at Plymouth University
and I I don't generally teach but I've
given them talks about technology and
music and science and music a couple of
times a year and what I also talk about
is my projects and one of the reasons I
do that is to try and get collaborators
to I say collaborators really just
people to do things projects like for
example I had one where I controlled a
wave tank with we regain control as I
stood on this gantry over a large
research wave tank and I would move them
and I could make waves be generated in
the water and the ways were turned into
sound by high sensors so I was kind of
playing this swimming pool sized wave
tank as an instrument and at the same
time there's a mini wave tank behind me
which had seven people in it doing what
water drumming inspired by the back of
African tribe where they actually slap
and pummel the water to create rhythms
but the point is these seven they were
all undergraduate students at Plymouth
University and they I remember when I
was trying to get people interested in
the project and I don't think this is
unique to any particular school or
university you found there was a divide
between kind of the very good goal
focused people who would kind of make a
commitment and turn up and really buy
into a project and the people who seemed
very interested but they always seemed
just a little bit too busy to turn up
when you needed them and i was i was
fortunate you know I what I did
basically if I felt that somebody was
not interested in the project I would
rather have fewer water drummers than
risk having someone disinterested on
there just to fill a gap I was fortunate
I ended up with seven people you have to
have some leeway because these p
weren't being paid I did I gave them a
co composition credits on the second
movement of the piece so you know so I
gave them something but you know you um
so they're not getting paid so you have
to you can't be like a task master you
can't be like you must do this you must
do that you're 10 minutes late then but
but you get a sense if people are
committed to doing it and so I think it
is important I I am in a privileged
position where I can come up with
unusual ideas and once you've had a few
successful unusual ideas people you know
it's in your job description art that
you have to do this and you have to
allow yourself to think freely and I
become a little concerned recently
because I've I've got to a point where
I've achieved more success than i
thought i could and things are
solidified just a little bit not not a
lot the things are solidifying in my
mind and my emotions a little bit what
constitutes a project and what sort of
artist i am and so forth and I thought
if I I need to keep mice I need to get a
stick into the kind of cement of my mind
and stir it back up and loosen it up
again because my value is in
consistently bringing together unusual
concepts and bring them together into a
new concept now if I become a person
that does that in a predefined way it's
very hard to explain better I I need to
keep spontaneity in what I do and I I
need to keep it's like there's part of
me that's nervous about reading too much
about my field because I worry if I read
too much that's close to my field that
I'll get fixed into thinking how other
people think about it and that I'll get
start thinking more about the field than
participating in it but if I don't read
anything what where's the input where
are the concepts that i'm going to put
together and I'm at a point now where I
haven't been doing a lot of reading for
the last year or so and I can and I'm
thinking where am I going to
my input from where am I going to go and
get these new ideas from see you need
input as well you know there's there's
got I feel there's got to be some goal
orientation there's got to be time to
think in a loose way you've got to give
the brain time can take days for it all
to come together so and and also you
need some input
you